it must be 10 o'clock
someplace
um
1004. I'd like to call the special
meeting of the fiscal committee to order
and we have one item on the agenda today
so uh representative Lynn has a motion
yes uh Madam chair I'd like to make a
motion that we take uh item FIS 22 404
off the table and accept the replacement
that has been provided
do I have a second
thank you Senator Bradley
all those in favor please raise your
hand
opposed
thank you
okay
um
it's probably best that we have a motion
to
um
accept
the replaced item and then we will have
discussion
thank you uh second all right
we'll need a roll call on this
one okay
yeah the motion is so that we can begin
our discussion okay actually I think we
can just
do a okay all those in favor
I opposed thank you
okay
um I would like to call commissioner
Caswell
forward
good morning good morning
Taylor Castle I've got Mark with Liberty
with me here's our Broadband program
manager
perhaps you could sure go through the
replacement item and want to start by
thanking uh you madam chair and members
of the committee for scheduling this
special meeting and making the trip down
here for uh today to consider this item
I wanted to just take a quick moment to
give you a little background on how we
have gotten here today
the history of the history of the
history of broadband expansion in New
Hampshire particularly in rural areas
has been one of frustration
despite a well-known need in these
communities to access an Internet that
becomes a more necessary part of
everyday life with each day that passes
there has been a lack of progress made
for many years
local select boards Broadband committees
planning agencies and others have been
unable to Garner the resources necessary
to make investments in high-speed
broadband
a major reason for this has been the
fact that many areas of the state
particularly in population centers have
excellent Broadband coverage and have
for many years
Federal funding agencies have seen this
and interpret it as a state that looks
largely served
this has resulted in most funding that
has been made available nationally being
sent to other states largely in the
South with large percentages of their
populations without any service at all
just a few years ago 20 percent of
Mississippi had no internet access in
lots of in areas of their state
on the ground here in New Hampshire this
has caused many efforts to expand
Broadband to lose momentum and has
resulted in massive service disparities
effectively creating a system of haves
and have-nots
from my perspective as someone charged
with advancing our state's economy this
is an untenable situation
even before covid we had large portions
of our state population without access
to a major tool for working learning
accessing health care and financial
management
during and after covid these tools have
become even more the norm and continued
disparity is impacting our economy and
making us less competitive
then in 2021 the state was awarded 122
million dollars to expand the reach of
our Broadband infrastructure
funds that would enable us to finally
answer the call from these communities
this time this moment in time is an
opportunity that we have never seen
before nor do I think we will see again
the opportunity we have to provide
access at scale Statewide is one we
cannot pass up
when we received These funds we set a
goal of moving quickly and efficiently
we designed a competitive 50 million
dollar Statewide program that sought to
get broadband service to the most number
of unserved and underserved locations in
the quickest and most efficient way
possible we have accomplished that under
round one of this program we will be
bringing service to 23 000 locations at
a cost of two thousand one hundred
dollars per location
that rate is the second lowest cost of
per location of any state and
construction is already underway
our request today is to enable us to
bring that same success to a second
round aiming to bring at least 15 000
more new locations online this time for
40 million dollars enabling this work to
begin immediately upon completion of
this process
in addition our item today includes an
accept and expend request for the next
part of our Broadband work this 25
million dollar request will fund the
first round of the Broadband matching
Grant initiative or bmgi that is
designed to fill out areas that are not
addressed under the Broadband connect
program and we are requesting to use the
remaining 25 million dollars of the
capital project fund under this item and
at the same time committing to use
another 40 million dollars of funds we
are due to receive under the iija the
infrastructure Federal infrastructure
legislation enacted in November of 2021
I can't understate the degree to which
access to broadband has become a central
part of the state's economy
making these types of investments will
now will literally will pay off
literally for decades and put New
Hampshire in a position to compete in an
economy that is increasingly accessed
over the Internet small businesses large
manufacturers remote workers families
and the elderly are all finding more and
more ways to be productive to do their
business and to stay healthy by using
the internet communities without it will
be left behind perhaps never to make up
that ground that could be lost
so once again thanks for this
opportunity and Mark and I are here to
answer any questions you might have on
the item
thank you are there questions
representative Leachman
thanks Madam chair uh thanks
commissioner Mark for appearing
so a number of us have had questions and
some of them haven't been answered yet I
checked with Mr Kane just a few minutes
ago and I'm still kind of waiting on
questions uh that I've had for at least
a week or two and I know Mark and I
tried to connect via the telephone but
we're never successful
uh
the concern I have is we're not
following if you will the law that we
established make sure that as many
possible communities could get service
and we've gone this route that's kind of
bypassed the process that was so heavily
debated as far as the Broadband matching
Grant initiative and I know and I
appreciate that you brought that back
with the 25 million dollars today but
I've heard from so many people prior to
our special meeting and prior to our
last meeting when we tabled the item
that they've tried repeatedly I'll take
the town of Hancock for instance it's um
just north of Peterborough they have
areas that have dial up still they've
made I think two separate applications
for funding and been denied what
assurances because you just told us that
you see fifteen thousand new hookups if
you will
that doesn't seem like an awful lot so
the people in Hancock are they gonna
have any possibility of getting service
or are they going to be pushed back on
another burner other communities up
north because it just seems that this
hasn't been rolled out that well we're
still looking for maps we've asked uh
repeatedly that how do we stand where
are the areas that have service or no
service I know you've got several
different definitions of underserved and
um
if that still says that people within
those years do have some sort of
broadband but it doesn't say who doesn't
have anything or has dial up so that's a
question I've been putting forward for
weeks about where are the areas that
have nothing have those been identified
as priorities that I can't seem to get
an answer so so you got a lot there let
me try to let me try to get some of
those representative so with regard to
uh bmgi I think it's important to point
out that
um we had to make some changes to that
legislation in the previous legislative
session in order to make the program
align with the program rules for the
capital project fund the federal money
that we were going to use to fund the
bmgi program
and so Mark and the team uh at in our
Broadband office worked with legislators
to come up with a number of changes to
the pre the previously enacted bmgi
Statute in order to make those
accommodations one of which was to
change the match uh to a 75 percent
match on the side of the state for that
program we achieved that at the end of
the session last year in July and worked
immediately went to a JL card to start
the interim moves process which we
actually completed just prior to our
last fiscal meeting so as far as the
standpoint from where we are
that is very much within the schedule
that we have been pursuing which has
been to get bmgi in position to be uh to
utilized with the funding under the
substantial funding that we have
available to us under Capital project
fund and ultimately under the iija and
to use those funds to effectively
backfill the program of the Broadband
connect program the Broadband connect
program has been put in place in order
to effectively get to those low-hanging
fruit let's call it places in the state
that have have had long-term difficulty
in getting service for high-speed
broadband and broadband service
generally so the the competitive process
that we used identified those areas and
we're now hitting what did I say 23 000
different locations and how many
different communities
73 communities six counties all North
and Western 73 communities around the
state so
as part of that process we recognize
that there were still some areas that we
could get with this program with the
Broadband connect program and so we
initiated a second round
that will that we are asking for the
accept and expend today to mirror those
those results
bmgi is a program that will be a
partnership between providers internet
service providers and local communities
to identify places literally like at the
end of cul-de-sacs within their
communities within their regions to
jointly make that application to
continue the sustainability the build up
of a sustainable Broadband
infrastructure within the state so I
think it's important to recognize that
this is all part of a long-term strategy
with a significant amount of resource
that gets us in a place to be able to
set a foundation of reaching communities
that just frankly have not been touched
from many years in a substantial way get
those online use the Broadband connect
program to build up I'm sorry the bmgi
program to build up the areas that would
be not covered under the Broadband
connect program all said and done by the
time we spend 122 million dollars under
this program Plus at least an additional
100 million dollars that we are
expecting out of the iija program that
should be a very resilient Broadband
infrastructure Network for the state
I'll follow up if I could manage here
yes you may thank you
so you just struck a nerve with me you
said that you're going to try to touch
those areas that haven't been touched do
you have that
a list of those communities that will be
touched under this program like again
I'll use Hancock for instance because
I'm more familiar with that are they
going to be touched by this program I
don't know specifically if Hancock was
in in
um round one we have just received the
applications for round two so I wouldn't
be able to say at this stage what the
towns are that would be under the
winning uh awardee but I again I I
having having reviewed the applications
of round one we did not see a
significant amount of overlap in a lot
of those applications so I would expect
that we will see new communities in part
certain areas of the state that would be
covered under round two and then again
we still have the bmgi program that will
be coming behind that
I'll let someone else go up next
uh Senator Rosenwald thank you madam
chair
um I see that this if
uh accept this item we will have spent
all but five million dollars of that 122
million and I'm just wondering why
you're why you're holding back that 5
million is it a requirement or well it's
a combination of things we've also
funded the mapping program as you recall
um there might have been one other
program
yes so uh to continue uh uh some
assistance with a consultant that we
will be having an RFP for shortly and
then the administrative costs of the
department so paying Mark and his and
his team
are there further questions
Senator Bradley
um good morning thank you very much
Madam chair
so a couple of things
um
I really appreciate the fact that you've
accelerated the bmgi funding
um to put the 25 million dollars into
what I think that will have a better
chance of reaching those areas of the
state that
um
may not have been touched with round one
and who knows exactly the winning bidder
of round two
um so I I think that's vitally important
so I appreciate that to me that was one
of the bigger problems of the fiscal
committee consideration two weeks ago
um
we've talked about this you know
privately but can you
um
talk a little bit more about the iiga
funds and where they are when we can
expect them and
um how guaranteed they are I think
that's a critical component
so I'll start and I'll ask Mark if he
has anything he wants to add on this but
I do think that uh that legislation was
enacted just about a year ago and
um the federal government is in the
process of deploying resources under
that fund there have been resources that
have come to New Hampshire through New
Hampshire D.O.T uh the funds that are
specific to broadband or under What's
called the bead program
those funds are due to become available
probably by the second quarter of
2023. so again in terms of the timing
that we're looking at working with here
having the rules in place being able to
launch the first 25 million using the
funds that we already have in hand and
then anticipate a point and when those
funds would be exhausted pull another 40
million dollars from that ihja program
further yes follow-up
um thank you very much
so in the bmgi legislation
um when I first introduced it it was a
50 50 Grant then I think it was Senate
Bill 445 that was Senator Hennessey's
bill
um that a number of us co-sponsored it
changed as you noted to
um
75 to 25 percent but the question that I
have and we've again talked about this
offline there is a requirement under
bmgi that there be a provider match
whether it's municipality or the
provider and most likely the provider
and what you've indicated to me is that
as round 2 progresses and as it goes
before the governor or Council there'll
be a requirement that there be a at a
minimum of 25 percent matching
commitment by the provider is that
correct in case that's correct yes yes
sir
um okay so the answer to that is yes
uh lastly there's been
um I think
questions that have Arisen out of
um
round one and duplication of services
um bmgi was meant to
try to get internet to areas of the
state that had no service so
um
the question that has been Arisen has
arisen is the duplication if you will
and how are you going to verify the
addresses of where you know the wires
are going to be
um
installed
so a number of ways as we go through the
uh award the review process for round
two
um we we consult a number of different
sources including the FCC mapping data
that I think has been discussed
um previously I I I do think that that
by itself is not a sufficient amount of
uh address level specific data to be
able to
sufficiently meet the needs under the
capital projects fund and so uh for
example that process the FCC
477 mapping really goes only down to the
level of census block which as you know
in New Hampshire is often a very large
geographic area so effectively if there
is service in that census block they
check the box that that has that's an
area that has service I think our
experience on the ground is that's not
always necessarily the case so again it
tends to overstate New Hampshire's
served population and and by itself is
probably an inadequate tool I would note
on a side note there that as a result
several States including New Hampshire
are going to be petitioning the FCC to
seek ways to improve that those mapping
tools that they uh that they have
available for us so in order to overcome
this we will be working as we have in
the past to review all the addresses
that are submitted under the RFP
on round two with the applications and
with others we will be partnering with
the communities that have done a
significant amount of work in
identifying served in unserved areas
through their own processes whether it's
a bonding process or whatever other
process they might have and we also will
be conducting spot testing to identify
the speed and reliability
in areas with where there is currently
existing services in order to make sure
that they are meeting with the capital
project fund standards
um I guess this is as much common as
anything else
um and and I think a tribute to uh the
chair
um who's worked with myself and
commissioner Caswell to make what I
believe is a much stronger
um presentation now to the fiscal
committee
um with the commitment to move forward
with the next 40 million dollars of
funding that I think I am relatively
assured now is going to happen the 25
percent
um contract matching Grant and the
um
it'll be a process over time of the
verification of addresses but um
those are all very helpful and obviously
moving up the
bmgi into this proposal I think is very
helpful so I would hope Madam chair that
we can
um vote for this and be on our way
thank you Senator Bradley representative
or if you have a question
uh thank you madam chair and quick
commissary Casbah
so
I've been trying to get this question
answered since prior to our last
meeting and I thought it would be a very
simple
a question to ask but how is it that the
intent of RSA 12-0 colon 63 Roman
numeral 2.
isn't to require that Federal Broadband
funds be controlled by the rsa's 12-0
colon 61-63 and if you're not familiar
with those they're essentially the
Broadband initiative sections
so can you just repeat your question for
me
yes sir
how was it the intent of RSA 12-0 colon
63 Roman number two which is the one
that talks about putting the funds into
the bmgi fund we talked about putting
Broadband funds into the dmgi fund
isn't to require that Federal Broadband
funds be controlled by those same rsas
so looking at 063
you established the Broadband matching
Grant fund the fund shall be kept
separate and distinct from other funds
and shall be continually appropriated to
the to Bea for the purposes of the
subdivision
any federal funds received by the state
for purposes of expanding or improving
internet access that are not otherwise
committed to other programs or required
by the federal legislation authorizing
the funds shall be deposited into the
Broadband matching Grant fund is that
your question that's the answer I'm
referring to yes and and which and
specifically
what about that language
authorizing the funds shall be deposited
into the Broadband matching Grant fund
which I assume is the bmgi fund we're
talking about yes sir
so
for the purposes of expanding or
improving internet access that are not
otherwise committed to other programs
so the not otherwise committed to other
programs is what your
that's what you're suggesting is the out
to
that's what you're going by they
consider that that is the authorization
for us to run the Broadband connect
program as well as bmgi
a follow-up
go ahead thank you for that certainly
so
I just want to clarify this in my mind
the understanding is that a law drafted
in 2021 which is when hb2 which is the
law that we're talking about here was
drafted and signed into law
by a combination it actually has to be
85 but sp85 didn't come into effect
the understanding that that was drafted
in 2021 during a time when was unclear
what federal restrictions would apply to
a distribution or Broadband funds
included a clause that intended to give
whichever state agency would oversee the
distribution of funds broad discretion
to ignore the law as drafted and do what
they chose with the funds as opposed to
the Clause that same Clause we're
referring to here being included as part
of the effort of the drafting of that
legislation to not lose the federal
funding due to an inconsistency between
federal and state laws and as I'm sure
you're aware in other areas of the of
that law there are specific references
to of trying to avoid that problem
let Mark talk a little bit about this
issue he's been
foreign hi there thank you for the
question so when we read this again any
federal funds received by the state for
the purposes of expanding or improving
internet access that are not already
otherwise committed to other programs
that is why we are here I think for us
other programs are this program the RFP
process and that was why it was so
important and we have said this back in
2021 we said this during the 445 SB 445
and why we went to fiscal in July to
approve round one is to get that those
funds as we say committed to other
programs so we've been open about saying
okay these are how we're going to
utilize these funds and put them into
these programs and get the approval of
the proper entities both fiscal and
governor and Council
one more follow-up yes please thank you
for that I actually did try to read
through the Senate minutes from I
believe the meeting you're referring to
regarding SB uh 85 from 2021.
um could you just refer me to where it
where you raise those issues at that
meeting
we actually raised it at February 1st
2022 during the Senate Bill 445. the
whole process is when we received this
funding uh we got this information for
this funding for capital projects that
was in September of 2021 and actually as
we were reading drafts and the final
bill for infrastructure it was clear
that we wanted to make sure that when we
had Broadband matching Grant initiative
ready to go that the funding source the
funding and the law itself could could
coincide plus there was also an ask
about the changes in the match and that
was from both municipalities and isps
had reached out about that so that's why
we went through that process
if you remember at the time when we went
through this process there was going to
be a commitment of an x amount of money
into the Broadband matching Grant
initiative
um during that process we were clear
that we wanted to be able to have the
flexibility to utilize those funds but
in exchange we would come to fiscal and
governor and Council for anything that
we decided to do what programs we wanted
to move forward with so that was during
the conversations in February of 2022
for the amendment
thank you very much for that I really
wish I could have gotten that
information a month ago when this whole
process started so that I would not have
been put in this position but thank you
representative Lynn did you have a
question no okay
Madam chair I'm sorry Senator uh Khan
thank you madam chair
um so I I'm
I think that
passing this uh today provides some
clarity to towns that are
have committees up and running
uh that are trying to
follow the guidance that we've provided
and it might have Broadband bonding and
town meetings coming up where an action
today will help that overall
communication throughout the state I
think that's important
uh I also think that uh
understanding because we won't reach all
of the need with this
allocation with this proposal
and that with the promise that there is
more coming
through a defined process the
legislature has participated in
that encourages towns to come forward
with proposals which is what the bmgi
was designed to promote in partnership
with providers
um
to understand then what is that full
build out and I I think I'm through this
process Madam chair I think we have
learned there's been a more disclosure
of what those dollars are 25 million and
40 million that are known today can you
add something more to that as to what
those decisions might be you said by
June site at the end of the second
quarter you might
no further about iija funding
what would that be so that the towns
that are active not receiving funding in
this next round to solve their what
their overall needs
uh so that as they
come forward with their proposals public
hearings that they need to hold between
the second quarter of
23 and the end of calendar 23. I'm
trying to then get that that picture
that you can paint for us as the how How
deep the bucket is going to be uh it's
more than 65 million dollars
that's correct yeah and so um I guess in
terms of the process is that sort of
where you're going with this like how
we're going to proceed or I'm I'm
looking for a dollar amount how I you
can put a border on that uh border that
that amount clearly it's no less than 65
million dollars so the amount of money
we expect to see under iija yeah yeah
okay
um I I might let Mark answer that
question he's been really uh in
communication with U.S treasury uh way
more than I have so he might have some
insight for you on that
yes so it's a separate program so
capital projects fund is do U.S treasury
the infrastructure bill is ntia and the
FCC working together
they have that program bead program
which is the majors funding source for
that program is 42.5 billion dollars
Nationwide every state is going to
receive a minimum of 100 million dollars
we don't know what that final allocation
is going to be they're going to going to
tell us that sometime in mid to late
June of 2023. so that number could be
higher we don't know so we're we but to
be do what we're doing we have to stay
with I think the most conservative
number we can and treat it as a hundred
million dollars so you would have that
40 million dollar commitment there's
still 60 million minimal minimum that we
could look at for other avenues and
those funding mechanisms are for
unserved then underserved in what's
called tier three is connecting anchor
institutions so working with communities
to determine other areas that to make
sure that communities are connected
Beyond just locations but work with the
communities determine what some of their
needs are
and the timing for The Madam chair
please go in timing then that you see
for subsequent rounds would be what
um the census you get the number in June
of 2023
um we're we have um been getting an
indication from the Feds that we're in
the right track moving forward with
everything so my sense is by the end of
2023 we should be being able to utilize
those funds for additional programs and
these funds I believe go until 2028 so
um whatever that number may be and like
I said if it's 100 or 120 or whatever
that may be we'll have a better sense
when that happens we can let you know
that because we do that quarterly report
for fiscal to get that information out
we can include that information in part
of that report so then when we know more
we can tell you all
thank you and I can call you directly
because you won't be on this committee
anymore if you want
thank you
representative Edward you had a question
uh thank you madam chair
um I uh I'm generally in support of this
I'm not voting today but uh as I'm
listening to this we heard a description
from representative leishman that we
still have places out there relying on
dial-up and uh I I think it's going to
be great when those dial-up places get a
100 Meg by 100 Meg but the technologists
I've been talking to
um suggests that we're going to be going
to an eight gig standard in 2025 or 26
uh it'll be rolled out nationally with
five five gig down three gig up which
will be amazing that'll support all
kinds of 3D applications and immersive
Technologies and so so my question for
you is as as we're investing this money
now are we basically going from sort of
a horse and buggy era to a Model T or a
right when we see you know the
interstate highway system getting ready
to be rolled out are we are we
anticipating well this technology
deployment uh support the emerging eight
gig standard not the hundred hundred Meg
but the eight gig
so in in a Senate bill 85s and then the
bmgi law one of the things that was put
in there is that we need to look at at
least what the next steps are how do we
get everybody at least one gig that was
more I don't know if it's aspirational
or but look for strategies to get to us
at that point so it's not quite the five
and three but it certainly was an
indication from this legislature to look
to the next steps so during our process
not only did we meet with all of the
providers of landline of of ground fiber
wired but we also met with starlink we
also met with project Kuiper which is
Amazon we've met with a lot of different
people to kind of give us a sense of
what are the next steps and we hear that
and so the great part about it is is
like yeah you could go from there you
could go to even higher we're hearing
the different companies saying well
these Technologies bring us all the way
up to 2gig right now so what can we do
for more than that I think where
bead is going to come into plan the
connecting anchor institutions talks
about what you're looking to do because
then you're going to have hospitals
you're going to be looking at that sort
of for example hospitals if they have to
send x-rays or some very intense
um documents they want us to be looking
at that we talk to the Telehealth people
about that so we have to keep an eye on
that and I think our process through
bead and the iija will be to do that and
keeping track of that sort of thing and
that's why I think they've also extended
it to 2028 so we'll certainly be trying
to stay on not not necessarily the
bleeding edge but The Cutting Edge of
where things stand
yes you may one uh thank you madam chair
okay so I I just want to put something
Away In My Memory Bank on this what I
think I'm hearing you say is that yes
you're aware of the emerging gains that
we're seeking in our Broadband bandwidth
uh but what I'm not hearing directly is
that yes you believe that the
Technologies we're investing in and
deploying are going to be inherently
capable of that because I'm concerned
that if we aren't inherently capable of
meeting that next technology wave then
we will be back here in five years
looking for another
200 million dollars so I I just want to
make sure we're we're investing in a
flexible way or a way that will support
the future
I believe the way that we're doing it
and then the feds using their guidance
and we've been using it we're future
proofing the internet for the State of
New Hampshire so yes I believe the
technologies will get us to those places
I believe that the infrastructure will
get us there
yes Senator Daniels
thank you
establish that
that there are continuously shout there
some with no service and some that are
underserved slower speeds uh We've also
established that the money that's being
requested today will not cover
everyone so my question is about the
process of selecting in your selection
process as to where this money is uh to
be used
could you talk a little bit about uh how
that's going to be used when you compare
the underserved versus the no service is
one going to have a a priority over the
other
so in the RFP process that was we were
leaving it to the to the the applicants
to determine those areas and so that way
we weren't necessarily picking the
winners or losers so we're going to let
everyone apply and then we go through
the verification process and do what
needed to be done in that way
bmgi will be municipalities working
directly with the providers themselves
in in a local area to make those
determinations as well and what's going
to be great is that they will the
municipalities will have a say in
working with whom they decide to work
with so those questions can be answered
by them and for us we'll be granting
providing the resources based upon the
application and making sure everything
is approved and that the scoring
requirements are met but those things
will have happened at the municipal
level between the towns and the
providers
thank you
I do have one are there any further
questions
I do have one uh quick question
um when I read the RFP uh it indicated
the proposals had to be in by the 28th
uh can you tell me how many people apply
or whatever
I can say how many three okay thank you
appreciate that
yeah
okay
um
seeing no further questions
well the clerk please call the roll
we have a motion
random motion okay yeah
yeah
the uh leishman Bradley motion at the
very beginning so that we could um
discuss it with a motion on the floor
Emrick votes
representative erf yes
representative leishman yes
representative Lynn yes
Senator Daniels yes Senator Moore I mean
sorry Senator Bradley yes Senator gray
yes Senator Rosenwald yes Senator Khan
yes representative umberger yes Madam
chair the vote is 10-0 in favor the vote
being ten to zero the uh replacement FIS
22404 passes
and um I just want to thank everybody
for uh coming out to this meeting today
and I want to thank Bea for the work
that they were
accomplished in the last week or two
with Thanksgiving interrupting a lot of
a lot of what was going on
so there will be no other fiscal
committee meeting in the month of
December I can see big smiles from
from people that may be serving on it
next year so our our first fiscal
committee meeting will be in January
sometime
so with uh nothing else I will oh yes
Senator Bradley
um I think it's really important that we
all pay tribute to you madam chair to
Senator Daniels to Senator Khan for the
work that you've done for all these
years I think it's exemplary and we're
going to miss you and thank you the
three of you very much
you're welcome
uh Senator Rosenwald thank you uh the
echo those sentiments event also like to
thank the LBA for their always Stellar
work and Staffing that's committee
okay I would just like to wish everyone
a very happy holiday season
and uh get some rest and relaxation and
be ready to hit the road running January
2nd so thank you very much have a good
day adjourned